è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj e non ci siamo tornati
sui service virtus erano rimasti che
dovevo togliere ste cose che è che sono
una cosa impossibile ovviamente per
farlo dovrei essere io solo che non lo
so non è la fine i ragazzi ho scoperto
che era casi devo guardare in basso così
in modo da devo cercare una merda dei
cani in giro una volta che chiesta una
testa passa devo andare ecco perfetto
così camminare senza alzare lo sguardo
pregando di non tirare una craniata su
qualcosa e devo riuscire ad aria ecco
come ho detto ok perfetto devo arrivare
davanti a sto tizio dove c'era l'occhio
l'ultima volta eccoci qui perfetto
adesso devo alzare lo sguardo e
guardarlo e aspettare che che vada in
botta al personaggio credo se sì che
culo
credevo non funzionasse però meno male
che è andata bene e adesso veramente
siamo strafatti di canne giunti a che
bella sati cos'è gran voce amica via
benvenuto pellegrino secco non sono fa
vj comunque al cospetto di per il tas
fonte di ogni verità tempo avverte
riconoscerle potere di controllare il
tempo
eccolo celo celo ragazzi e quello che mi
serve per andare avanti in poche parole
posso posso guardarvi le bocce pronuncia
questa formula ti al buddha sticazzi che
pop
ha fatto funzionare ora che non ci credo
ha funzionato
cazzo non era questa la magia mi
cambiano ti sei sbagliato è però va bene
va bene anche così ragazzi non posso
ancora lì o non detto un cazzo non posso
ancora aprile cioè non posso arrivare
ancora le colonne mi serve un'altra
magia devo tornare per gli eventi
indietro allora ragazzi devo usare dove
cazzo era ecco questo perfetto cioè le
tette grosse non il piano da graziano
sono riposato
quando attenta vantare tutino sono
riusciti ad oltrepassare quel cazzo di
punto finalmente dopo anni dato le porte
rosa sono mi sembra di entrare nel
castello delle barbie ma non fa niente
se arriva cos'è sta roba
le cazzo incominciata di casi proust
amica mi ha detto lumen
adesso siamo a posto andremo fermi
regata ti aiuta mi chiami storica mi
dicono che sta gioca non è per chi ha la
memoria di uno scarafaggio dovremmo
esserci in teoria se le mie doti da
diana jones mi stanno dicendo le cose
giuste
ecco lumen ecco lumen ecco devono
svuotare un polmone per dio st troiano
adesso rapporto sia aperta dovrei
muovere il culo per riuscire ad arrivare
alla fine se riesco io
[ __ ] però ci la cena di benvenuto
d'angolo è come trojan o yahoo da ok ok
mai mai mai mai mai se i ragazzi ce
l'abbiamo fatto per meno male che le mie
doti mi aiutano perché sennò non sarei
non sarei qui ragazzi c'è un altro
incantesimo credo sia quello è un
incantesimo e la lista della spesa non
ci capisco bene ma credo sia la prima
speriamo il tuo diario è stato
aggiornato vediamo che c'è scritto la
telecinesi fino a milano
questo senza neanche leggere sono
funzionali alla l'asso già perché io io
io sono esperto listino che va da te
mingardi un leviosa wingardium leviosa
leviosa le bio già cosa parte leviosa a
un crampo alla mano non si sa perché è
passato dire o un pick n
quello allontanati avvicinati
pronunciando acton amec razza pianeta di
junior come un pick n
obi wan kenobi
rialzi e bellissima com'era l'altro da
mac
ecco allora che io direi lì proseguire
per bernard mac prossimo sarà del
trasporto mi dicono se riesco a trovare
il gol
ragazzi siamo ancora ancora la gemma
cioè ha buttato a terra una gemma che
varrà mezzo milione di dollari legata a
mac non sa cos'è rami cono obi wan obi
wan kenobi ob ob e basta ok perfetto
regalo perfetto stiamo andando benissimo
sarà anche dove sta già dottore dove
sono le colonne e tulum è tenuta la
rotta nelle mouse che cazzo di
stregoneria e mai questo mi manca il
corpo legato al fatto che mi manca il
corpo nome fa un essere umano a girare
la testa di 180 gradi
come sai niente post cioè che casa un
gufo capo i file forza e coraggio forza
e formaggio da heineken è possibile una
porta che cazzo bravo il gel chi dava di
goku tra l'altro perpetra una mecca il
genchi dama ragazzi tra un po punta
freezer non lo so è però ho i miei dubbi
ho sollevato le colonne che una magia
che rimarrà nella storia
e tra l'altro
e tra l'altro tra un po diventare una
sottiletta ma fa niente l'abbia fatta la
caccia alla funzione non non chiedetemi
come ma ci siamo
adesso dovrebbe crollare il ragazzo
perfetto come come come andare a finire
nella merda nel modo peggiore possibile
ma ce l'abbiamo fatta da questo punto in
poi ragazzi la demo in teoria si
concludeva non c'era più niente quindi
da adesso in avanti proprio non ho idea
di che cazzo andremo a vedere anche
prima ce l'avevo perché la diverso ma
adesso a maggior ragione proprio zero
zero assoluto e svegliarsi italiani è
stato aggiornato perfetto questa
stagione si aggiorna da solo perché ma
che cazzo adesso rumore
salve sono qui di passaggio ok gas in
un'idea di che cosa sia sta roba che mi
lanciano addosso buongiorno work e o
puntare ok perfetto ragazzi qualcuno che
separa fiamme non ho idea di chi sia ma
non mi piace per niente la cosa ma se ti
pure chi ha facessimo scattino veloce
mentre passa così a meno corrotte come
fatto mai veloce ragazzi dai già faccio
due che già faceva chiazzo ok ho visto
fortissima lega dove già nuda o donna
che sa mica non ce la farò mai più una
cosa così epica
perfetto allora mi sono salvato il culo
in una maniera che non so come ok va e
veloce veloce ti aiuta si ok perfetto no
ho fatto un salvataggio pazzesca non
credo che riuscirò mai più a darmi così
salve ragazzi c'è un tizio bello e sono
anche caduto non so dove
incassiamo chi cazzo sei tu riassetto
lumen via via le mani dal culo non è una
manciata di cazzo è sotteso legati ma
una partita a carte non lo so magari mi
presti un tentacolo nei tre erano piano
piano di avere un organo non mi segue
non mi segue sa sarebbe sta roba di pre
perché si è bloccato poi vabbè io non ho
capito bene che cosa dovrebbe essere
questo ammasso di tentacoli però
lasciamo perdere prima che che si
incazzi di nuovo quindi andiamo via
prima prima che succeda qualcosa di
magari si addormenta in piedi credo mi
serva un'altra magia per passare forse
quel tizio mi può aiutare ma ecco
perfetto piano da
ragazzi hanno capito come si dovrebbe
uscire di qua non si riesce a fare una
sega all'acqua del the new gas
ok allora riusciamo a capire dove devo
devo andare ancora non funziona più una
sega in sta merda cazzo si è sbagliato
ragazzi ragazze svegliato si è svegliato
al tizio è salva credo anche di aver
capito via lo dà ok
credo di aver capito cosa devo fare ma è
un po difficile però ti devi togliere i
[ __ ] bravo si alluda [ __ ] tua
sorella pezzo di stronzo veloce yachts
di ma le primarie prima rientro email e
prima dietro di noi dentro raccordo
ragazzi direi che possono chiudere più
questo episodio perché dal prossimo
iniziano anche a lanciare magie per fare
i culi però vabbè lasciamo perdere non
vi spoiler o nulla regalo ma sento
servito da piaciuto il suo trattamento
mi piace anche al vaglio di facebook
come la divido tra la descrizione solo
se ve ne siete iscrivetevi ci vediamo al
prossimo windows belle ragazze